what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that you think we
really should be there is a really thick
online culture of Reddit and different
social media where they're all affirming
each other in a very female empathetic
way and it's making people feel worse
and worse and worse so it's kind of
toxic empathy where everybody's oh it's
really hard for you oh it's really hard
for you and nobody is willing to do the
hard challenging conversation everybody
is so empathetic and kind to each other
and it's all oh don't worry it's very
unnourished CU nobody will give it to
you straight truth has a value yeah and
depth has a value and it's vacuous I
think there's a a real
genuine toxic culture I know everybody
says it but I think we're not talking
about just how toxic it is to be a
teenager these days I think it's I think
it's really hard and I think they're
suffering on a deep level it's really
unfortunate cuz we've never had it so
good